kimberley it's just so you know another
horrible tragedy on a Friday in this
country it seems like this almost once a
month at this point what jumps out at
you after you hear something like this
anything specific and anything that you
can reflect on for the audience yeah and
when you think about it you can feel it
right the heartbreak it's heavy
you know everybody feels it you hate to
have to even report on a story like this
to see it happening the family members
people are suffering you know including
the parents of even the shooter in terms
of what happened what went wrong people
probably thinking to themselves a sense
of guilt responsibility what could I
have done to prevent something you know
like this but they get the number of
casualties is heartbreaking those
injured and thoughts and prayers to the
families and also to the hospital you
know workers the nurses the doctors
everybody who moved in to try to save
lives so that there weren't even more
fatalities but what I'm thinking about
right now is that I know that in terms
of the investigation they really do have
to do a deep dive into his social media
into any kind of motive mental state but
also is there anyone else that he
communicated with they were also going
to be questioning a couple other people
they're concerned and they've set up a
very large you know perimeter in case
there are any explosive devices that
have been secreted around the property
or the area of the school that could
still cause harm so right away you're
gonna want to be questioning this
individual to determine to see to make
sure that there is no further loss of
life or casualty in a situation like
this and you see kind of the elevation
shot so they're gonna do that and really
check the area to make sure there isn't
anything else that doesn't go undetected
and he was supposed to take his life he
did not take my own life and he's in
critical condition so law enforcement
Gregg gonna be able to interrogate him
pretty thoroughly yeah I don't want to
hear from him but I you know we had we
did this fun story for the last couple
days the Laurel and yannis thing I can't
help but see every news story now
through that prism and because everybody
goes into their separate sides
it's either Laurel which is we need more
armed security or it's Yanni there are
too many guns and it's too many guns
versus not enough and I think that the
only way that we're gonna get through
this
stop and move beyond it is if we get out
of this to this prison of two ideas and
actually seek a compromise from both
sides to look at okay what effective gun
control measure would work well I always
talk about a system that tags certain
people considered to be high risk by
teachers and authorities a civil court
that tags this person so they can't have
guns the problem is with this guy he got
his he got the guns from his parents so
he gets through so the other thing then
is to trained more armed personnel
because the variable that affects
casualty rate is the duration between
the first gun that is unholstered and
the second gun that arrives to stop him
if it indeed stops him or any kind of
hard target that comes is a response
weapon right so this is a these are two
things that come from two areas one
comes from gun control which is a court
that provides a civic tag and then you
also have armed personnel which is what
people believe enhances freedom
insecurity is to have somebody there who
knows what they're doing but the third
thing as always is the media and the
media has to be aware that blanket
coverage creates incentive for more of
these events because it creates it
creates infamy and this is about infamy
this is not like street crime this is
the type of crime that is a symbolic
nihilistic act that what that the person
does so they can live forever and in our
heads and it works because we constantly
do blanket coverage so if we have to
learn how to pull back from this and not
talk about this person and not mention
his name because we're just gonna create
more of them he's training on Twitter
yes and one of the things that people
were alarmed by Dana was he had this big
trench coat and in Texas which is very
hot and people said why wearing it well
apparently though I had an opportunity
to anchor the hours with a trace
Gallagher and one of the people one of
the students that we interviewed she
said that he wore the trench coat every
day what was different today was that he
wore a t-shirt underneath it that said
born to kill Oh God so who knew that it
was interesting in interviewing those
students all three of them were women
young women they are so poised and
mature and articulate and able to put
their thoughts together but I did think
it was very disturbing and I'm sure for
parents it's very disturbing that all of
them also said that they weren't
entirely surprised that they sort of
expected that this might happen to them
because as we was saying we we cover
them and it happens all too often the
other thing that was similar is that
they had just done some fire drills and
active shooter drills at this school and
they had had some resources actually
that had taken from the state in order
to get that done and I asked one of them
do you think it helped yeah to save
lives and she said absolutely because
they knew what to do and one of the
teachers the band teacher was actually
able to put them up into a room that is
a has a solid concrete walls because so
that nobody can hear the music being
played and so that teacher was very
quick thinking the hospital had also
just done a drill so they are a level 1
trauma center so they were able to solve
lives very quickly and I think Greg's
made this point very well before which
is that on all ends law enforcement
schools and the medical teams in
particular modern medicine is amazing
but because they have done these drills
they are able to save a lot more lives
more quickly I also would point people
to look into Charles cook he writes on
national review about this obsession of
copying the Columbine high school
shooters
it's almost textbook and you can go
through it's very chilling when you look
at it and it becomes a little bit of
this thing of if we're gonna be in this
prison of two ideas we're gonna have
this fight in the meantime it's almost
like you don't know how to stop it
because they're online and they're doing
this the only possible thing that you
could do more drills and a hardening of
targets Congressman Michael McCall who
is from that district this is so such a
small world thing just yesterday he
introduced legislation that would
provide for grants and money for schools
across the country to take actions as
they see fit but including certainly
these types of drills and then and I
said would that money be tied to
anything in particular he said no and
the last point I would make is that the
lieutenant governor gave a press
conference in one of the things he said
is that this shooter took the guns from
the father he's only 17 years old he's
not supposed to have the guns in any way
and they just implored parents that if
you have weapons that you legally own
make sure that they are locked up and
that your children can't get ahold of
those
excellent point and the weapons he used
a 38 revolver and a shotgun Richard yeah
I think Dana's right and I pulled a
quote from one of the young ladies and
my name is Paige and this is what she
said I quote no there wasn't it has it's
been happening all over I've always kind
of felt like eventually it was going to
happen here I wasn't surprised I was
just scared ah and I was I watched her
interview and as we're preparing for the
show that quote stuck out to me because
I think I'm one of the younger folks at
this table and I was just like I
literally graduated from college ten
years ago and he never had active
shooter trainings when I was in high
school and that was 14 years ago and to
think that these young people today are
saying at 17 yeah like I almost expected
it to happen at my school and so when it
happened I wasn't scared and it meets me
this is that something's got to give in
this country that we've got to really do
everything in our power as adults and as
lawmakers and as people of influence to
make sure that every single school in
this country is safe welcoming and
thriving and I think Greg is right we've
got to be in the middle right part of it
is how we harden soft targets and the
other part is how we restrict access to
guns right and part of it is making sure
the people who have guns are responsible
and making sure that if you are a gun
owner and you're a parent and you have
young people in your house you lock
those guns up so they don't have access
to them and mentally stable absolutely
and the other part is fixing the and
President Trump said it himself making
sure that we commit to fixing the
background check system right but we've
got a cop in this case in particular it
would attract to do because anyway and I
think the other thing that it that makes
this even more sobering for me is that
this weekend for these young people is
graduation weekend and so some and will
as leave these and we're gonna hear more
stories as we go into this weekend about
some of these young people and I'm
pretty sure some of them should have
been wearing a cap and gown this weekend
and they won't be days we used to do
earthquake Charles that's the biggest
danger in San Francisco for students
tornadoes unfortunately it's become a
part of the routine for some high school
students in this country all right